playing rustamov strong gm
i feel like i've played him before in
the same line
also i'm minimizing chat
alerts muted
okay so it's a it's hippo time
requires patience
might be overly patient here but uh
[Music]
i don't want to commit to anything
unnecessary
is this idea
and this pawn chain undermines the
bishop
i could go for d5
hmm
uh queen e2
i don't really want to commit
to d5 too soon
okay there's this idea
it's kind of slow looking but
ah well played okay i have this
could have considered taking two
i just have to make quick decisions
f5 is gonna be the main plan
my five ideas
[Music]
considering this and then
f4 f4 is generally not a break to play
but
it could make a lot of sense
can i have five also on the horizon
i mean black is asking for it
bishop takes
oh wait wait wait okay pawn takes i of
course win the queen expecting this
i'm giving up d5 but g6 is very tender
ah another four
four takes
there's a fascinating line
i might sack the queen
like 94 i might just take it
it's fully intuitive
the only thing i see is 96 is the front
this is also a threat
oh no my queen
i have a freaking bishop for it
how does bach defend
i'm trying to find the
move for black here
just take and then here
there's queen d2
oh there's a funny line
[Music]
so queen d2 rook e6
writing g7 checkmate
i cover e1 still so there's no dumb
perpetual
oh my gosh
ctrl alt is it ctrl alt
on your promote to knight checkmate
wow
okay i had all the queen turned on i
wasn't sure it was controller alt
so i held down both
that could have been tragic if i i mean
if i promote a queen i think it's
maybe still winning
wow
you don't get to do that too often
that's yeah that would be a rose and
trophy if that was on me chess
i don't know if i've ever done this
before
even in like a joking game but this was
like a serious game
where i have to
have to promote with check
oh i miss i miss maiden one
uh
but uh
i mean the only thing i saw was
push and then make a horsey
i think there's um
yeah promote tonight with checkmate
have i ever achieved this
on me chess i i think that's the one
that i'm missing
wow
i've never had promotion tonight on
leches so that was the first time in my
life